irina y su hijo pequeño huyeron juntos
de la región de dmitro el pequeño de dos
años sufre un neuroblastoma un cáncer
muy agresivo del sistema nervioso la
guerra interrumpió por completo su
tratamiento y
precisamente ahora se había complicado y
por culpa de la enfermedad mi pequeño no
va a aprender a caminar
llegaron en un corredor humanitario
hasta esta clínica en el sur de polonia
mientras una fundación estadounidense
les busca asistencia en otros hospitales
de europa
nihat espero que ayuden a mi hijo para
que pueda crecer como los otros niños y
tener una vida normal
la hija de ivana padece un linfoma de
hodgkin acababa de terminar la
quimioterapia en la región de bowling en
el noroeste de ucrania
curso
ahora teníamos que hacerle una
resonancia para ver los tumores pero el
hospital de que ha sido cerrado
como otros padres teme desesperada que
como consecuencia de la guerra el
proceso de curación de su hija se vea
interrumpido
además de haber sido diagnosticados y
tratados por enfermedades muy graves
estas familias sufren también la
incertidumbre en la que está sumido su
país
y finalmente 15 de estos niños consiguen
ser evacuados en autobuses se dirigen
hacia utrecht holanda donde van a
recibir el tratamiento que ellos
necesitan en un hospital especializado
en oncología pediátrica así hasta 850
niños ucranianos han pasado por esta
clínica que les ofrece una segunda
oportunidad para que puedan seguir con
la que su lucha puede recuperar su salud
y los días de su infancia